Bem-vindos de volta
ao FP101x.
Vamos começar
contando um pouco da história
da programação funcional.
Quando olhamos para linguagens como
Java ou
JavaScript, é fácil de esquecer que
os conceitos de programação funcional
são na verdade muito antigos e
eles foram
inventados antes da maioria de nós
ter nascido.
Aqui vemos Alonzo Church.
Alonzo Church
na década de 30, desenvolveu o
cálculo lambda.
Ele desenvolveu o cálculo lambda
como uma base
para a matemática. Ele queria encontrar
uma forma
para descrever os fundamentos
da matemática
e é bastante notável que seu trabalho
na década de 30 acabou se tornando
a base para a maioria das nossas
linguagens de programação de hoje.
Se você olhar para o Javascript,
a linguagem que alimenta a web -
e todos nó sabemos que em Javascript
funções
são muito importantes - alguém
poderia falar
que a web é alimentada pelo
cálculo lambda.
Agora Java 8
tem expressões lambda e C++
tem
expressões lambda... Não há
linguagem de programação em uso hoje
que no suporte este conceito que
Alonzo Church inventou na década de 30.
Se formos
um pouco mais para os
tempos atuais, na década de 50, John
McCarthy
desenvolveu o Lisp, que não só foi
uma das primeiras
linguagens de programação já projetadas,
mas também foi a primeira
linguagem de programação funcional.
John McCarthy
foi influênciado pelo cálculo lambda,
mas ele também
tinha atribuições imperativas
em Lisp.
De certa forma você pode falar que
Lisp foi uma das
primeiras linguagens de programação
modernas que combina
as idéias do cálculo lambda puro
com algumas das características imperativas das
linguagens de programação.
Em 1960,
Peter Landin desenvolveu ISWIM.
ISWIM significa "If You See What I Mean"
e esta foi a primeira linguagem
funcional pura
baseada no cálculo lambda, que sigfinica
que não havia atribuições - apenas
funções puras.
Na década de 70, John Backus
desenvolveu a FP, que significa
"Functional Programming". John Backus
passou a ser um dos designers do Fortran,
que foi concebida mais ou menos na mesma
época
que a Lisp e era uma linguagem
muito imperativa.
Ele desenvolveu essa nova linguagem
nos anos 70
que enfatiza higher-order functions
e, espeficicamente, raciocínios sobre
programas.
Você quer ser capaz de raciocinar sobre
sobre a exatidão
do seu código e FP é
focada nisso.
Também na década de 70,
Robin Milner, que você vê aqui,
desenvolveu a ML.
ML também era uma linguagem hibrída  que
pegou idéias da programação funcional
pura, mas também
permite atríbuições imperativas.
Um detalhe interessante sobre ML é que
ML foi originalmente desenvolvida
como uma linguagem de script.
Foi desenvolvida como uma linguagem de script
para permitir pessoas escreverem provas.
Quando você está escrevendo provas
matemáticas, há muitos clichês,
muitos passos que você tem que fazer
e a fim de automatizar isso,
Milner e seus colegas de trabalho
desenvolveram ML
tal que você poderia escrever scripts que
fariam todos estes passos
tedioso por você.
Uma das
vantagens da ML - tenha em mente
que isso foi
na década de 70 - era a inferência de tipos.
Então, vocẽ poderia escrever uma função e
o compilador inferiria o tipo para você.
ML também tinha
tipos polimórficos, ou como os chamamos
hoje principalmente, tipos genéricos, onde você
poderia ter
a uma lista de T e então instanciar T
com Int ou String ou
talvez mesmo uma outra lista.
Estes conceitos de inferência de tipo
e genéricos são na verdade bem velhos
e isso
levou muitas e muitas décadas para
estas idéias
sairem da acadêmia
para o mainstream.
Nas décadas de 70 e 80,
David Turner
desenvolveu algumas linguagens,
começando com SASL,
então KRC e por fim culminando
na Miranda. Estas eram todas
linguagens funcionais lazy
e nós iremos ver a diferença entre
lazy
e linguagens funcionais strict mais
tarde no curso.
David Turner foi extremamente
influente pois
Haskell, a linguagem que iremos
usar neste curso,
é também uma linguagem lazy e é
construida
em muito do trabalho feito por
David Turner
na Miranda, SASL and KRC.
Minha primeira linguagem funcional,
quando comecei a estudar ciências
da computação
na década de 80, foi SASL, então
eu ainda
tenho um lugar especial no meu coração
para a SASL
e nós iremos definitivamente dar uma
olhada
nisso mais tarde em uma sessão de SASL,
pois SASL de alguma forma é
a mãe
do Haskell.
Falando de Haskell, por volta
de 1987,
um grupo de pesquisadores
de linguagens de programação e
linguagens funcionais
iniciou o desenvolvimento do
Haskell e a idéia era de
criar uma linguagem padrão que
as pessoas poderiam usar para experimentos.
Porque se você quiser experimentos
com, digamos, um novo sistema de tipos,
é muito trabalho construir toda uma
infraestrutura
da linguagem, do parser, etc,
se tudo o que você quer fazer
é estudar esse novo sitema de tipos.
Haskell tem sido chamado as vezes
de placa de Petri por pesquisadores
de linguagem de programação
e tem servido a esse objetivo e
tem vários artigos tem sido escritos
onde Haskell é usado como
substrato para experimentos,
mas Haskell também tem tido
bastante sucesso como linguagem.
Haskell será também
a linguagem que usaremos neste
curso. Em 2003,
isto é bem interessante,
o relatório Haskell 98 foi publicado,
isso foi alguns anos
depois da linguagem ter sido
finalizada.
O objetivo do Haskell 98
foi definir uma versão estável da
linguagem.
Haskell sendo este veículo de pesquisa
tem tido muitas extensões a fim de
fazer a linguagem
ser usada no mainstrem,
a idéia era que nós precisavamos de
uma versão estável da linguagem
que apenas tivessem características
que fossem
consistentes e terminadas, tal que
as pessoas pudessem confiar nela.
Nesse meio tempo, Haskell tinha se
mantido
em evolução, mas neste curso
iremos aderir
ao Haskell 98.
Se você está usando o GHC, como você irá ver
na proxima aula, o GHC
tem muitas extensões, mas esse
é
um tópico para um curso futuro.
Vamos ficar apenas com Haskell 98.
Se olharmos
o status do Haskell hoje, há
a plataforma Haskell,
que você pode baixar, o website do
curso terá todas as informações
sobre isso. O website do curso
também terá informações
sobre outras formas de executar
programas em Haskell
e links para outras linguagens que
você pode usar para fazer os exercícios,
mas a plataforma Haskell fornece uma
implementação da linguagem Haskell
mais as bibliotecas padrão para a maioria
das plataformas: Windows, Mac
e Linux.
Este plataforma Haskell é utilizada em
toda a indústria
para entregar software real
e também, como veremos,
você pode ver a influência de Haskell
em outras linguagens.
Vamos terminar por aqui
com um pequeno programa em Haskell
para mostrar a concisão do Haskell.
Este propgrama aqui,
o que ele faz
é: ele ordena uma lista usando o algoritmo
quicksort.
Aqui está o código;
Here's the code; vamos passar por ele e
depois de algumas aulas você será capaz
de escrever código como este sozinho.
A primeira coisa quando ordenamos uma lista
é: quando temos uma lista vazia -
este é o primeiro caso aqui -
queremos ordenar a lista vazia e
o resultado é uma lista vazia. A
lista vazia já está ordenada.
Agora o próximo passo aqui diz que se
temos uma lista
xs que começa com o valor x,
o que fazemos é: primeiro
what we do is: we first
pegamos todos os elementos a que são menores
do que x,
colocamos eles na lista chamada ys e então
pegamos
todos os valores b que são maiores do que x,
colocamos eles na lista
zs
e então o que fazemos é ordenar
recursivamente
ys com a função f,
então todos os vlaores que são menores
do que x
serão ordenados. Então ordenamos todos
os valores que são maiores do que x
(que era zs) e então concatenamos
estas duas listas com x no meio.
Você pode facilmente ver que
o efeito desta chamada
recursiva é que agora nós temos uma lista
ordenada.
Aviso: Este programa
apenas mostra a estrutura algorítmica
do quicksort - mostra a decomposição
recursiva
da ordenação. O quicksort real, em
uma linguagem
imperativa, não cria novas listas
como aqui
(estas 2 listas), mas pega uma lista única
e modifica os valores em vigor,
tal que use apenas o espaço
desta lista única.
Mas ainda assim, se você quer
estudar a estrutura algoritmica do
quicksort,
este programa é bastante elegante.
Claro, podemos começar com este
programa e então podemos querer
implementar isso
de uma forma mais eficiente
através da mutação de estado.
Muito obrigado!
Este foi o final a primeira aula.
Happy hacking
com os exercícios no website
e vejo você na próxima semana
para a aula 2.